The Black Comedian Who Was Almost One of the
Three Stooges
There’s a good chance you’ve never heard
of Mantan Moreland.
But, if you are lucky enough to have seen
him in a film—any film—you’ll definitely
remember him.
Moreland’s comic timing manages to transcend
the decades in films like King of the Zombies
(1941), where he steals the show, saving what
would otherwise be a completely forgettable
(and by now, probably long-forgotten) comedy-horror
flick.
While changing attitudes about black roles
in film may have hastened Moreland’s fall
from popularity, he’s finally being rediscovered
as the talented character actor and comedy
genius that he was.
Had history unfolded just a little differently,
Mantan Moreland would most likely have never
become forgotten in the first place.
In fact, he once came awfully close to being
cast as one of the Three Stooges (more on
that later).
In an era when segregation was in full swing,
the fact that he was strongly considered to
be part of the internationally-known trio,
let alone be the choice of Moe and Shemp Howard
themselves, speaks to his considerable talent
as a comedian.
Cutting his teeth on the brutally competitive
vaudeville stage, Moreland honed his comedy
skills doing several live shows a day.
Vaudeville was a cutthroat business.
With dozens of performers waiting in the wings,
any act that faltered for even a moment would
be yanked—if not booed—off the stage.
Former vaudevillians like Charlie Chaplin,
Buster Keaton, and Bob Hope owe their cinema
stardom largely to the quick-thinking and
high level of professionalism required to
make it big onstage.
It worked for Moreland, too.
His talent as a comedian on what was then
known as “the chitlin’ circuit”—the
string of nightclubs and theaters deemed safe
for black comedians during segregation—soon
led to roles in movies.
Moreland’s earliest roles were in “race
films,” made with black actors for black
audiences.
His first screen role was as a night watchman
in a haunted pawn shop in That’s the Spirit
(1933), followed by a small role as an angel
in The Green Pastures (1936), a retelling
of Biblical stories as black American folklore
(Rex Ingram, Disney’s original choice for
Uncle Remus, played “De Lawd”).
Moreland was quickly moved up to supporting
roles in all-black westerns like Harlem on
the Prairie (1937) and Two-Gun Man from Harlem
(1938), playing the comic sidekick to Herb
Jeffries (better known as the Bronze Buckaroo,
America’s first black singing cowboy).
Recognizing his talent, studios soon snapped
him up to play comic relief roles in mainstream
movies (in other words, with white casts),
but his real break came when he was paired
with Frankie Darro in a series of crime comedies.
The two appeared in the films as porters,
bellhops, or pages who stumble across murder
cases (hijinks, of course, ensue).
While Moreland’s performances are stereotypical
of the era (he’s always the frightened one),
the films represent a huge turning point on
the part of the studio: Moreland and his white
co-star are depicted as friends and equals.
A high point of the series is when he and
Darro recreate one of the bits that made Moreland
a hit on the stage.
The “indefinite talk” bit appears in Up
in the Air (1940), and pays homage to the
routine he developed with Ben Carter, in which
the two would finish each other’s sentences.
Like this:
Moreland: “I haven’t seen you since…”
Carter: “Longer than that!”
Moreland: “Last time I saw you, you lived
over…”
Carter: “Oh I moved from there.”
Moreland: “Yeah?”
Carter: “Sure, I moved over to…”
Moreland: “How can you live in that neighborhood?”
The series came to an end when Frankie was
drafted during World War II, but Monogram
hung onto Moreland, recognizing him for the
amazing talent he had.
Perhaps intentionally, he was featured in
some otherwise-lackluster films, injecting
a healthy dose of humor where there would
have been none.
King of the Zombies (1941) is perhaps the
best known, and nearly every single line spoken
by Moreland is memorable, from “Move over,
boys, I’m one of the gang now!” to “If
there’s anything I wouldn’t want to be
twice, zombies is both of them.”
(You can watch the film here.)
Moreland was somewhat less valued at other
studios, where he didn’t receive top billing,
but his role in Universal’s The Strange
Case of Dr. X (1942) caught the eye of Three
Stooges cast member Shemp Howard.
The two appeared together in a gambling scene,
and Howard was impressed with Moreland’s
comic timing.
He suggested to brother Moe that Moreland
would be the perfect replacement stooge, should
the need ever arise.
Meanwhile, Moreland was cast as chauffeur
Birmingham Brown in Monogram’s series of
Charlie Chan films.
While “chauffeur” certainly doesn’t
sound like a memorable role, Moreland, as
usual, made the character one of the most
memorable parts of the series.
In fact, he was the only actor to stay on
board for the entire run, appearing in 15
of the 17 films.
In two of the Charlie Chan films, Moreland
got to reprise his indefinite talk bit with
original vaudeville partner Ben Carter.
Both The Scarlet Clue (1945) and Dark Alibi
feature versions of the routine that made
him famous, and the movies are worth a watch
if just for those segments alone.
When the series ended in 1949, Moreland saw
less and less work.
Some attribute his disappearance to the decline
of the B-movie in an era that was embracing
television, but many historians and biographers
think it had more to do with changing political
attitudes.
Black men as servants and chauffeurs were
not seen as funny so much as demeaning.
It didn’t help that Moreland’s shtick
was to play the skittish, frightened man—another
stereotype.
On the other hand, his performances always
seemed to transcend stereotype (and those
who knew him said that the deep Southern accent
and the expressions were true to how Moreland
really was).
His scared-out-of-his-wits characters are
really not that different from the ones played
by Bob Hope (see The Ghost Breakers, 1940).
It’s easy to understand, though, why Moreland’s
scared routine sits a little uncomfortably
today, especially as he plays a servant to
white men to boot—which is not something
Bob Hope had to do.
Remember Moe Howard’s suggestion that Moreland
would be a great Stooge if the need arose?
The need did just that in 1955, with the death
of Shemp Howard.
At a time when Moreland could have used the
work, the comedy team suddenly had need of
someone with brilliant comic timing and plenty
of experience.
Moreland biographer Michael H. Price talked
to Howard about just what a great idea it
was:
Mantan was responsive, when Larry (Fine) and
I talked the idea over with him.
I mean, we’d all seen our better days by
that time, but ol’ Moreland, – now there
was a talent that could’ a’ invigorated
the whole act!
He had the word play – you ever heard him
do that ‘anticipation’ routine, where
he and one or another of his partners finished
each other’s sentences? – and he had the
physical shtick, the jive moves and double
take receptions that would’ a’ filled
in the gaps when Jerome (Curly) and Shemp
had kept covered.
The studio had other ideas, though, according
to Howard:
But of course Columbia (Pictures’ management)
demanded a white guy, because they’d apparently
been scared off of Mantan, and we ended up
with that prissy damned Joe Besser, who was
whatcha might call a pain…I’ve always
thought what a great act the Stooges could’
a’ stayed for a while, if only we’d’
a’ gone with Mantan.
And that was the end of that.
Having appeared in over 300 movies in his
career, Moreland then only worked sporadically
in the industry until his death in 1973 from
cerebral brain hemorrhage.
His last featured role was as a doomed delivery
man in 1964’s weirdly wonderful comedy-horror
film Spider Baby, and though the role was
small, in true Mantan Moreland fashion, it
is not easily forgettable.
He played a few more blink-and-you’ll-miss-them
roles, wrapping up his film career as a man
almost run over by a motorcycle in the soft-core
film The Young Nurses (1973).
Moreland made a few TV appearances on shows
like “Adam 12” and “Love, American Style”
and released a few raunchy “party records”
on the Laff label, including That Ain’t
My Finger (his “mashed potatoes” punchline
famously appears in the Beastie Boys song
“B-Boys Makin’ With the Freak Freak”).
One thing Moreland never stopped doing was
the indefinite talk routine that originally
made him famous, performing it up until the
last year of his life.
Mel Watkins, a black comedy historian, noted
that to black audiences, it was as well-known
a classic as “Who’s on First?” was to
white audiences.
Once so famous that his films bore his real-life
name (Mantan Runs for Mayor and Mantan Messes
Up, 1946), the actor is certainly not a household
name today.
While he deserves rediscovery, one thing’s
for sure: if Columbia Pictures hadn’t been
opposed to having a black comedian in one
of the most beloved comedy groups of all time,
he wouldn’t have needed to be rediscovered
at all, and his name would have been sealed
in mainstream comedy history.
If you liked this article, you might also
enjoy subs